it's like are you trying to bribe me and
you trying to bribe me right now like no
man no I'm not trying to bribe you I'm
just saying is there something that I'm
when they're getting arrested in Mexico
to make it like he never existed welcome
to this is not happening
I'm Roy Wood jr. when traveling make
sure
[Music]
Davidians over to the stage you all
noticed a man from his comedy album the
rifts in the game
my good friend Bob Christiansen
[Music]
I'm 35 years old and I got to tell you
guys it feels great to be halfway done
we're halfway there baby I'm getting old
and I'm trying to smile more I am
because I realized that sometimes people
will look at me and they'll get nervous
that I'm gonna freestyle rap at their
house party I might do it it's gonna be
all originals with a limited vocabulary
[Laughter]
but really sometimes people look at me
and they'll think that I'm a dick
because I have a resting dick face I
have to think about why do I look like
that and I really think it's because for
a long period of my life I sold drugs in
Brooklyn and when you work in that kind
of line of work it's good to look like a
dick just wanna like
[Laughter]
turn it up sorry when I was young man
like before 18 I used to go on drug
adventures with my best friend Gary and
like we fly to Portland Oregon
we buy an ounce of meth and then we fly
it back on a plane hide hidden in our
butt cheeks and it was before 9/11 and
before 9/11 it was so easy to fly drugs
on an airplane our favorite trip that we
used to take is we go down and see one
of Mexico and we buy ketamine it's the
90s I'm sorry and we get ketamine and we
take it back across the Mexican border
we did this a whole bunch and we knew a
lot of bad people and a lot of good
people doing bad things and people were
overdosing and dying people going to
jail and I felt like I was running out
of chances so I had to get out of
Brooklyn so I joined the Air Force and
that straightened me out enough to go to
college and it gave me money to go to
college so shortly after that I found
myself going to California Polytechnic
State University in San Luis Obispo
California it was very different than
Brooklyn it's like the first time where
I understood why people didn't like
white people
like I've met people whose parents were
still married people whose parents were
suits to work they were saving
themselves till marriage they were going
to church every Sunday I was terrified
[Laughter]
but I was doing well and I was cleaned
up and I was healthy I was happy and my
best friend back in Brooklyn Gary he did
the same thing went to college he was
happy he was healthy got a little money
decided to visit me so it comes out to
California Gary is a Russian Jew the
only reason that I mentioned he's a
Russian Jew is because he's a walking
cartoon of a Russian Jew he knows where
you could buy a wife and he'll haggle
the price for you he came to San Luis
Obispo we were there just three hours
north of Mexico and we're feeling good
we were feeling healthy and we decided
hey for old times sake let's just drive
to Mexico and commit a federal crime
we had a ritual that we do every time we
rent a car we go down and we'd be the
first ones there the Granero when they
opened up to buy ketamine first ones in
line well there was no line we're the
only ones buying ketamine but if there
was ever a line we'd be first then we
would take the ketamine and we'd
immediately shoot it up with syringes
all right listen I didn't shoot it in a
vein okay I'm not like a heroin addict
I'm better than them I was shooting the
butt cheek or arm muscle and the muscle
I'm not gross and then we get higher in
ketamine and we walk towards the beach
on the way at the beach we would hit the
fruit stand I would buy a mango cuz I
don't know how to cut a mango the nuts
too big I always slip I cut my hand I'm
too dainty for that and when we finally
got to the sand we would rent sad horses
by the time the horse ride was over we'd
be sober enough to get back in the car
and go back to America and this was the
ritual we did over and over and over we
had it like clockwork must have been
like 30 times he bought Kaede 30
different mangoes you went and we rode
30 horses I mean it probably wasn't 30
different horses you know it's probably
like repeat horses because they only had
like 17 horses and horses get sick you
know hard to take care of his stuff and
like you couldn't keep a stable of 30
horses that'd be crazy but still I got
on thirty saddles is what I'm saying
and everything went according to plan we
got back in the car and then we would
drive deeper into the city to a quiet
place where we would find a place to
transfer the drugs and hide them to go
back to America what we do is we'd empty
tequila bottles and then empty the
liquid ketamine into the tequila bottles
and reseal them so when we get to the
border and the Border Patrol be like yo
dog will you bring him back and I be
like yo son I just got this tequila he
was like no doubt enjoy America and then
I played the national anthem and I will
cross the border that might not be how
Border Patrol they just took I don't
know I may I might be I might be
misremembering that part so I see a
place that looks quiet and I turn up
this block and I end up going the wrong
way up a one-way street and on that
Street is an SUV filled with four
federales they see me lights and sirens
pull me over pull me out of the car
search the car
find all of our ketamine so now we're
screwed I'm on the curb there I got a
gun in my face and I'm actually nervous
about this gun thing
this is the first time I've ever been
nervous when I had a gun in my face in
my life it was the third time I had a
gun in my face the first time I had a
gun in my face is when I was 16 years
old and I got caught writing graffiti in
Brooklyn and a cop put a gun in my face
but I wasn't nervous that I get shot cuz
I'm a white dude in America and we don't
get shot I could literally be waving a
gun around and they'd be like sir calm
down calm down sir can we get you a soda
the second time I had a gun in my face
it was put there by my arch-nemesis in
Brooklyn a white crip named Willy boats
and I wasn't nervous when Willy put a
gun in my face because Willy boat is a
bitch you ain't gonna do
[Applause]
but this time the third time I got to go
to my face I'm nervous and the reason is
because this time I'm an actual bad guy
I'm a drug trafficker I'm a drug tourist
you know so the people back in San Luis
Obispo where I came from they don't see
a difference between a drug tourists or
a sex tourist or a hit man for the Mafia
it's all just bad people to them and I
think if this cop thinks I'm a bad
person he might feel it's within his
rights to actually shoot me and I don't
know if I blame him for it so I'm taking
advantage of his country but I've been
in a lot of situations with cops before
so as soon as they try to talk to me I
know exactly what to do I immediately
started crying it was wet tears down
rosy cheeks might have been a little
snot involved the goal was for him to be
like there's no way I'm gonna put this
little bitch in jail and they separate
us like cops do to interrogators try to
get us to mix up our stories and I was
such a drug addict at the time there was
no way I was gonna rat out my drug
dealer so I wanted to scream a story
loud enough for Gary to hear so he can
repeat the story
[Laughter]
and gallery scream back I don't know we
just bought it off some weird dude
outside of a hotel that looks like a
carnival close enough Gary you're
gangster
it's my G right there
kept the connect so now they realize
nothing's gonna happen the interrogation
we reach the final part of this where
it's like what we can we gonna go
somewhere like to a dirty Mexican prison
or what's gonna happen and so I stopped
and I was like hey man is there like is
it like something I could do to make
this go away the cop got mad he's like
what are you talking about what are you
saying to me right now I was like I
don't know maybe like can I give you
something and then this doesn't happen
you know like what is this something's
like are you trying to bribe me and you
trying to bribe me right now like no man
no I'm not trying to bribe you I'm just
saying is there something that Americans
do when they're getting arrested in
Mexico to make it like it never existed
and the dude was like you give me money
but I didn't have no cash on me and
Gaddy didn't have no cash on him because
we spent every dime we could on drugs so
I was like listen man I gotta go I could
get it out of an ATM and for some reason
Geary didn't have any money in the ATM I
still don't know why to this day he
didn't know for a piss ATM card they're
like all right no doubt you go to the
ATM and get some money for us and we're
just gonna hold Gary we're just gonna
hold Gary to make sure you come back so
now I'm on my way to an ATM and I'm
nervous cuz like I got my boys life in
my hands I mean we turned around at this
point we weren't hardcore drug dealers
no more we were just like kids trying to
have fun again like we were college kids
now we were straightened up this is not
supposed to be happening I couldn't let
myself go out like that and I certainly
couldn't let my boy go out like that so
I hit ATM I put the card in doesn't work
something with my car being an American
car and I'm getting nervous I hit
another ATM the same thing it won't work
so that's it I'm at the like last point
where I'm just like God please God if
you just let me get this money out the
ATM and get out of this situation I
promise I will never ever do drugs again
and I hit the third ATM and boom I get
the money out I pulled out like 250
bucks which is like three million pesos
[Laughter]
and I rushed back to go save Gary when I
get back the situation's changed Gary's
now sitting in our rental car white is a
ghost I don't know what they said to him
to make sure he didn't move that
car and then I look in the back and all
the cops are back in the SUV
and the SUV door just opens on its own
like a horror movie and I know that they
want me to enter their little horror SUV
so I get into the backseat and I climb
in and now I'm in between two federales
and there's two in the front the dude
who's driving is the leader and he asks
for the money I give it to him he counts
it and he was happy with the amount and
he was like alright get out of here and
I'm just like I did it and I'm climbing
out I was like that was so easy I can't
believe it was just 250 bucks to get out
of this and I'm halfway halfway out the
back of the SUV and I get a hand on my
shoulder and a cop spinning me around
I'm like this is it
this is the gun in my face a knife and
my gut they're gonna cut my head off put
on the tourist in the desert
this is I knew it was too easy and the
cop spins me around I look and we make
eye contact knees like you forgot this
and gives me back all my drugs
[Applause]
then I jump back into our car we get
going we transfer our drugs and we're
going we don't say anything to each
other we just been through this like
traumatic experience and we're driving
and I and I feel Gary turning to look at
me and he's gonna say like the first
thing he said to me in probably 40
minutes and I'm like this is it
this is gonna be our first best friend I
love you I've been waiting for him to
say it I'm gonna say it back and I look
at him and I'm waiting for it and he
turns to me and he looks at me and he's
like you paid them way too much money
you could've gave him like fifty dollars
man why are you wasting that's more drug
money screw you Gary you owe me money
now we made it back and we were safe and
we did our drugs we did our drugs and we
haven't gone back to Mexico since then
to smuggle any drugs but I did I learned
a really important lesson from that and
it's that you should never ever drive
the wrong way up a one-way street
[Applause]
and also I'm not smuggling drugs no more
from Mexico but if by chance anyone has
some ketamine already in America I'm
just saying I got a birthday every year
hooked me up peace